- Selamat datang kembali di Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation.
Nama saya John Watrous dan
saya adalah direktur teknis untuk IBM Quantum Education.
Ini adalah pelajaran keenam dari seri ini dan merupakan pelajaran kedua dalam
unit kedua dari seri, yang membahas algoritma kuantum.
Di pelajaran sebelumnya, kita membahas model query
komputasi, dan kita melihat bahwa dalam model tersebut, algoritma kuantum bisa
memberikan keunggulan yang mencolok
atas algoritma klasik, termasuk keunggulan eksponensial dalam kasus masalah Simon.
Sayangnya, model query
tidak benar-benar memiliki relevansi
praktis yang langsung atau segera.
Gagasan tentang kotak hitam adalah abstraksi yang sangat berguna seperti yang ternyata, tapi kita punya beberapa pekerjaan untuk
dilakukan jika kita akan menerapkan
wawasan yang kita peroleh dari model query ke pengaturan komputasi yang lebih standar di mana input diberikan sebagai string bit
bukan sebagai oracle atau kotak hitam.
Tujuan utama pelajaran ini adalah untuk membangun fondasi
yang bisa kita lakukan itu.
Berikut ini gambaran umum pelajarannya. Sebagian besar pelajaran, kita akan berfokus
pada biaya komputasi,
atau dengan kata lain, seberapa sulit tugas komputasi yang berbeda dan bagaimana kita bisa mengukur kesulitan itu.
Secara kasar, ini diterjemahkan menjadi berapa lama kita harus menunggu
komputasi selesai dan pada akhirnya masalah komputasi mana
yang bisa kita selesaikan dan mana
yang di luar jangkauan kita.
Kita akan memulai dengan
beberapa contoh. Faktorisasi integer dan menghitung greatest common
divisor atau GCD secara singkat.
Ini adalah contoh yang sangat bagus untuk mengilustrasikan prinsip-prinsip dasar, dan keduanya juga kebetulan
sangat relevan dengan algoritma Shor, yang akan kita
bahas di pelajaran berikutnya,
jadi kita akan secara efektif
mendapatkan manfaat ganda dari contoh-contoh ini.
Kemudian kita akan membahas gagasan biaya komputasi secara lebih umum dan cara mengukurnya.
Ada banyak cara berbeda
yang bisa dilakukan, tapi kita akan berfokus cukup
sempit pada cara melakukannya dengan model circuit dari komputasi,
khususnya Boolean circuit
dan quantum circuit.
Fokus di sini adalah pada algoritma sebagai lawan dari perangkat keras komputer, misalnya, dan kita akan lebih peduli
dengan bagaimana biaya
menjalankan algoritma berkembang seiring instance masalah spesifik yang dijalankan tumbuh dalam ukuran daripada berapa banyak detik,
menit, atau jam yang diperlukan
untuk komputasi tertentu.
Ide yang memotivasi sudut pandang ini adalah bahwa algoritma memiliki
kepentingan mendasar.
Hingga hari ini, kita masih
menjalankan algoritma yang dikembangkan sangat,
sangat lama lalu dan sangat wajar, mereka akan digunakan
terhadap instance masalah yang semakin besar
menggunakan perangkat keras yang lebih cepat dan lebih andal seiring teknologi berkembang.
Dan cara mereka berkembang memberi tahu kita banyak
tentang seberapa berguna mereka dan seberapa berguna mereka akan terus menjadi.
Di bagian terakhir pelajaran, kita akan beralih ke tugas yang sangat penting, yaitu menjalankan komputasi klasik
pada komputer kuantum. Alasan ini penting bukan karena kita berharap menggantikan komputer klasik
dengan komputer kuantum,
yang tampaknya sangat tidak mungkin terjadi dalam waktu dekat jika itu pernah terjadi, melainkan karena itu membuka
banyak kemungkinan menarik
untuk algoritma kuantum.
Khususnya, begitu kita tahu cara menjalankan komputasi klasik
pada komputer kuantum, mereka menjadi tersedia untuk algoritma kuantum
sebagai subrutin
sehingga kita secara efektif bisa
memanfaatkan semua yang kita ketahui tentang algoritma klasik dalam mengejar keunggulan komputasi kuantum.
Komputer klasik yang kita miliki saat ini benar-benar merupakan keajaiban teknologi.
Mereka sangat cepat, tapi tidak begitu cepat sehingga tidak ada masalah komputasi
yang di luar jangkauan mereka.
Beberapa masalah komputasi
begitu sulit secara inheren sehingga meskipun kita memiliki
algoritma untuk menyelesaikannya, tidak ada komputer di planet Bumi saat ini
yang cukup cepat untuk menjalankan algoritma ini sampai selesai bahkan pada input berukuran sedang dalam seumur hidup manusia
atau bahkan dalam seumur hidup
Bumi itu sendiri.
Untuk menjelaskan lebih lanjut, mari kita lihat masalah
faktorisasi integer.
Pernyataan masalahnya sangat sederhana. Input untuk masalah ini adalah integer N yang setidaknya dua, dan outputnya adalah
faktorisasi prima dari N,
dan artinya adalah daftar faktor bilangan prima dari N bersama dengan pangkat yang harus dinaikkan bilangan prima ini
untuk mendapatkan N dengan
mengalikannya semua bersama.
Tentu saja, kita selalu bisa mengalikan faktor prima bersama dalam urutan apapun, tapi terlepas dari urutannya,
faktorisasi prima selalu unik untuk setiap pilihan N.
Fakta itu disebut
teorema dasar aritmetika, dan kalau kamu tertarik
untuk mempelajari lebih lanjut tentangnya, itu adalah sesuatu yang bisa kamu temukan
di awal sekali
dari banyak buku tentang teori bilangan.
Sebagai contoh yang sangat sederhana, berikut adalah faktorisasi prima
dari angka 12.
Ini adalah dua pangkat dua
kali tiga pangkat satu.
WEBVTT
Tidak mengherankan, sebuah
komputer bisa memberitahumu ini dalam sekejap dengan hanya mencari
faktor prima secara iteratif.
Berikut adalah contoh lain. Saya tidak akan mencoba membaca angka ini.
Itu sekitar 3,4 quattuordecillion, dan saya harus mengakui bahwa saya merasa aneh bahwa ada nama seperti itu,
tapi bagaimanapun, itu memiliki 46 digit desimal dan di sini kamu bisa melihat
faktorisasi primanya.
Sebuah komputer juga bisa memberi tahu kamu ini. Saya memfaktorkan angka ini menggunakan metode faktorisasi yang disertakan dalam pustaka matematika simbolik untuk Python,
dan itu butuh beberapa detik, yang bukan waktu yang sangat lama, tapi ada penundaan yang nyata.
Dan tentu saja metode factor N tidak menemukan faktorisasi prima ini dengan mencari faktor prima secara naif.
Sebenarnya menggunakan hibrida
dari algoritma yang berbeda termasuk satu yang disebut algoritma colored row, yang merupakan algoritma untuk faktorisasi
yang lebih canggih daripada mencari secara naif secara iteratif
untuk faktor prima, dan meskipun itu mungkin tampak
seperti angka yang cukup besar,
sebagai input untuk masalah komputasi, itu sebenarnya tidak terlalu besar sama sekali.
Hanya 46 karakter.
Berikut satu contoh lagi. Ini adalah angka dengan 309 digit desimal.
Kalau kita menulisnya dalam notasi biner, itu memiliki 1.024 bit dan itulah
mengapa disebut RSA1024.
Faktorisasi prima dari angka ini saat ini tidak diketahui.
Angka ini berasal dari
tantangan faktorisasi RSA, yang dijalankan oleh RSA
Laboratories dari 1991 hingga 2007.
Mereka menawarkan hadiah uang tunai
untuk faktorisasi prima dari berbagai angka dengan ukuran yang semakin besar, termasuk yang ini, yang bernilai $100.000 AS,
tapi hadiah itu tidak pernah diklaim.
Keamanan sistem
kriptografi kunci publik RSA didasarkan pada kesulitan
faktorisasi integer.
Kalau kamu bisa memfaktorkan, kamu
bisa membobol sistemnya, dan jadi tujuan tantangan tersebut pada dasarnya untuk melacak
keadaan terkini dalam faktorisasi.
Intinya adalah bahwa
memfaktorkan angka ini di luar kemampuan kita saat ini.
Sejauh yang kita ketahui,
masalah itu sendiri terlalu kompleks untuk komputer klasik
untuk diselesaikan dalam praktik.
Angka tantangan RSA terbesar yang telah difaktorkan sejauh ini, omong-omong, memiliki 250 digit desimal.
Mungkin agak sulit
untuk membacanya di layar, tapi berikut adalah faktorisasi prima dari RSA250.
Itu dilakukan pada 2020 menggunakan algoritma yang dikenal sebagai number field sieve, dan itu adalah upaya kolektif yang melibatkan puluhan ribu
komputer di seluruh dunia.
Sekarang, mari kita pertimbangkan masalah komputasi yang berbeda, yaitu masalah menghitung greatest common
divisor, atau GCD secara singkat,
dari dua integer non-negatif.
Berikut adalah pernyataan masalahnya. Input terdiri dari dua
angka kali ini, N dan M,
dan kita akan mengasumsikan bahwa
keduanya tidak sama dengan nol.
Tujuannya adalah untuk menghitung
GCD dari dua angka ini, yang merupakan integer D terbesar yang habis membagi baik N maupun M,
dan kalau kamu berpikir tentang
faktorisasi prima dari N dan M, yang akan kamu temukan adalah bahwa GCD adalah perkalian dari semua bilangan prima
yang membagi keduanya N dan M yang dinaikkan ke minimum dari pangkat yang muncul dalam dua
faktorisasi prima.
Jadi itu terkait dengan masalah
faktorisasi integer, tapi ternyata jauh, jauh lebih mudah
bagi komputer untuk diselesaikan. Kita bisa menghitung GCD untuk angka dengan ribuan digit
dalam sekejap.
Tidak ada gunanya mencoba menunjukkan contoh di layar karena kita bisa mengisi
seluruh layar dengan digit dan kita masih akan mendeskripsikan
instance masalah ini yang mudah diselesaikan.
Tapi kalau kamu tertarik, ikuti tautan dalam deskripsi video ke halaman buku teks untuk pelajaran ini dan kamu akan menemukan sel kode
untuk jenis komputasi
yang saya bicarakan, termasuk yang menghitung
GCD dari angka besar, dan kamu bisa mencobanya sendiri.
Pertanyaannya adalah mengapa ini mungkin untuk menghitung GCD dengan begitu mudah?
Dan jawabannya adalah bahwa kita memiliki algoritma yang efisien
untuk menghitung GCD.
Di antaranya adalah algoritma Euclid, yang ditemukan lebih dari 2.000 tahun lalu, tapi ada juga algoritma
GCD yang efisien lainnya.
Dan tentu saja kita berbicara tentang algoritma klasik di sini, jadi itu mengarah ke pertanyaan lain.
Bisakah ada algoritma klasik yang efisien
untuk faktorisasi integer
yang memungkinkan kita untuk memfaktorkan angka seperti RSA1024
dalam sekejap?
Dan jawabannya adalah ya. Tentu saja bisa ada algoritma klasik yang efisien
untuk faktorisasi dan saat ini kita tidak tahu cara apapun
untuk menyingkirkan kemungkinan itu. Yang bisa kita katakan adalah bahwa
kita belum menemukannya.
Untuk semua algoritma faktorisasi klasik
yang kita ketahui, kita masih pada dasarnya
mencari faktor-faktor
dan itu menempatkan angka-angka seperti
RSA1024 di luar jangkauan kita.
Algoritma GCD yang efisien,
di sisi lain, tidak bekerja dengan cara itu.
Mereka tidak mencari
greatest common divisor. Mereka secara efektif hanya membangunnya dengan prosedur mekanis yang biayanya kira-kira sebanding
dengan mengalikan dua
angka yang sama bersama, dan saya akan mengatakan sedikit lebih banyak tentang ini nanti dalam pelajaran.
WEBVTT
Tentu saja, ini semua membangun
menuju algoritma Shor, yang akan kita lihat di pelajaran berikutnya, yang merupakan algoritma kuantum yang efisien
untuk menghitung faktorisasi prima, tapi kita masih punya beberapa hal yang perlu dibahas sebelum kita sampai ke sana.
Selanjutnya kita akan membicarakan
tentang kerangka matematika yang bisa kita gunakan untuk mengukur biaya komputasi
dari algoritma yang berbeda,
termasuk yang sudah kita bahas.
Supaya jelas, kita akan berfokus sangat sempit pada circuit, yang hanya merupakan bagian kecil
dari subjek yang jauh lebih luas.
Mari kita mulai dengan tampilan tingkat tinggi dari komputasi biasa
dari pelajaran sebelumnya, yang berarti khususnya bahwa kita tidak memikirkan
tentang masalah query,
kita memikirkan tentang
masalah di mana input diberikan secara eksplisit sebagai string biner.
Seperti yang saya katakan di pelajaran sebelumnya, tentu saja kita bisa mengizinkan
simbol lain jika kita mau, tapi mari kita jaga hal-hal sederhana dan tetap dengan string biner
untuk input maupun output.
Komputasi itu sendiri bisa dimodelkan atau dideskripsikan dalam berbagai cara seperti dengan model komputasi Mesin Turing,
Boolean circuit, quantum circuit, atau program yang ditulis dalam
bahasa seperti Python atau bahasa lain pilihanmu.
Seperti yang saya katakan tadi, kita akan berfokus pada
circuit, Boolean dan kuantum.
Pertama, mari kita habiskan sedikit lebih banyak waktu untuk berbicara tentang input dan output, yang kita asumsikan adalah string biner.
Menggunakan string biner, kita bisa mengkodekan banyak jenis objek matematika yang berbeda, seperti angka, vektor,
matriks, grafik,
deskripsi molekul, misalnya, serta daftar semua objek ini dan yang lainnya juga.
Sebagai contoh yang sangat sederhana, jika kita ingin mengkodekan integer
non-negatif sebagai string biner, kita bisa menggunakan notasi biner.
Di sini dalam tabel ini, kamu akan melihat 13 pertama
integer non-negatif bersama dengan representasi biner atau pengkodean mereka.
Di sini di kolom ketiga, kamu bisa melihat panjang
dari setiap pengkodean ini, yang hanya merupakan jumlah total bit yang kamu butuhkan untuk pengkodean,
dan berikut adalah formula sederhana yang memberi tahu kamu persis berapa banyak bit
yang diperlukan secara umum untuk integer non-negatif N apapun.
Perhatikan khususnya bahwa
panjang pengkodean umumnya jauh lebih kecil
dari angka itu sendiri.
Ini logaritmik dalam angka.
RSA1024 misalnya, memiliki pengkodean dengan panjang 1.024, tapi angka itu sendiri tentu
jauh lebih besar dari itu.
Skema pengkodean ini bekerja
untuk integer non-negatif, tapi kalau kita ingin menangani
integer arbitrer, termasuk yang negatif, kita
bisa hanya menambahkan bit tanda.
Kita juga bisa mengizinkan sejumlah berapa pun nol terdepan dalam pengkodean ini jika kita ingin pengkodean
mengisi blok bit atau register dengan ukuran tetap
selama ukurannya cukup besar. Terkadang itu sangat mudah.
Ini bukan satu-satunya cara untuk mengkodekan integer sebagai string bit.
Ada cara lain yang bisa kamu lakukan, tapi ini adalah cara yang cukup
standar untuk melakukannya.
Untuk jenis objek lain yang mungkin membentuk input atau output ke masalah komputasi yang kita minati, kita bisa membuat
skema pengkodean lain.
Misalnya, pikirkan tentang bagaimana
kamu mungkin mengkodekan vektor atau grafik sebagai string biner atau pikirkan tentang bagaimana kamu mungkin mengkodekan
dua string biner ke dalam
satu string biner menggunakan hanya simbol nol dan satu tanpa spasi atau simbol lainnya
untuk memisahkan dua string. Tentu ada cara untuk
melakukan hal-hal ini, dan sebenarnya, kita punya banyak kebebasan
tentang tepatnya bagaimana kita melakukannya.
Seringkali tidak ada cara tunggal yang standar atau disepakati secara universal untuk mengkodekan apa pun yang kita bicarakan
sebagai string biner,
tapi tidak apa-apa, kita bisa memilih satu atau kita bisa membuat yang baru jika kita mau.
Dari sudut pandang formal murni, kita memikirkan komputasi sebagai pada dasarnya transformasi mekanis pada string bit
dan detail dari skema pengkodean yang kita gunakan tentu penting pada beberapa tingkat.
Tapi bagaimanapun, ketika kita merancang dan
menganalisis algoritma, kita biasanya tidak terlalu mengkhawatirkan detail dari
skema pengkodean.
Kalau kamu meminta dua orang yang berbeda untuk membuat cara mengkodekan, misalnya, molekul dari jenis tertentu sebagai string biner,
kamu mungkin berharap mereka menemukan cara yang berbeda untuk melakukannya, tapi jika ini adalah orang-orang yang wajar yang tahu apa yang mereka lakukan,
kamu juga bisa berharap secara wajar bahwa proses komputasi yang cukup sederhana untuk menerjemahkan bolak-balik antara dua skema pengkodean,
kemungkinan besar memerlukan komputasi yang sangat
mudah yang akan cukup mudah dibandingkan dengan komputasi sebenarnya
yang kita minati.
Intinya adalah bahwa detail mengenai skema pengkodean yang kita gunakan seringkali cukup sekunder dan fokus kita adalah pada
algoritma itu sendiri.
Tidak ada yang akan menjadi masalah untuk pelajaran ini, omong-omong. Kita terutama akan berfokus pada masalah yang berkaitan dengan integer, yang kita asumsikan dikodekan dalam biner,
tapi itu adalah sesuatu yang perlu diperhatikan.
Secara umum, untuk jenis masalah apapun yang kita bicarakan, panjang input mengacu
ke jumlah bit yang kita butuhkan untuk mengkodekan input,
dan kita memandang panjang input sebagai ukuran instance dari masalah apapun yang kita pikirkan.
Sekarang, mari kita pertimbangkan
komputasi itu sendiri, yang diwakili oleh
persegi panjang biru dalam gambar ini.
Cara kita mengukur
biaya komputasi ini adalah dengan menghitung jumlah operasi elementer yang diperlukan.
Secara intuitif, operasi elementer adalah yang melibatkan jumlah bit atau qubit yang kecil dan tetap
yang bisa dilakukan dengan cepat dan mudah seperti menghitung AND dari
dua bit, misalnya.
WEBVTT
Pada tingkat formal,
ada berbagai cara untuk mendefinisikan apa itu operasi elementer, tergantung pada model komputasi yang kita gunakan.
Misalnya, operasi elementer bisa berupa satu langkah dari Mesin Turing jika kita menggunakan model tersebut.
Untuk tujuan pelajaran ini, kita akan berfokus pada model circuit, seperti yang sudah saya nyatakan, dan khususnya kuantum
dan Boolean circuit.
Ketika kita bekerja dengan circuit, adalah umum bahwa kita memikirkan setiap gate sebagai mewakili operasi elementer.
Kita telah melihat beberapa quantum gate yang berbeda sejauh ini dalam seri,
termasuk X, Y dan Z gate, Hadamard gate, S dan T gate,
controlled NOT gate, swap gate, Toffoli gate, dan Fredkin gate.
Kita juga berbicara tentang query gate dalam konteks model query, tapi kita tidak akan bekerja dalam model query dalam pelajaran ini, jadi kita tidak akan mengkhawatirkan
query gate untuk sekarang.
Kita juga melihat bahwa operasi uniter apapun pada sejumlah berapa pun qubit
bisa dipandang sebagai gate jika kita mau melakukannya.
Untuk tujuan mengukur biaya meskipun, itu tidak akan sangat membantu, jadi yang akan kita lakukan adalah kita hanya akan
memilih set gate
dan kita akan memandang set itu sebagai set operasi elementer kita.
Pertama, kita akan memasukkan
gate uniter qubit tunggal yang kamu lihat di sini,
yaitu X, Y dan Z gate,
Hadamard gate dan S dan T gate, serta invers
atau conjugate transpose mereka.
Kita sebenarnya tidak memerlukan semua gate ini. Begitu kita memiliki Hadamard dan T gate, kita bisa mengimplementasikan sisanya,
tapi demi kemudahan, kita akan memasukkan semuanya.
Kita juga akan memasukkan controlled NOT gate, dan ini akan menjadi satu-satunya
gate multi-qubit dalam set kita.
Dan terakhir kita akan memasukkan pengukuran basis standar qubit tunggal sehingga kita bisa benar-benar mendapatkan beberapa informasi klasik
yang keluar dari circuit kita.
Jika kita hanya berfokus pada gate uniter dan melupakan
pengukuran sejenak, kita mendapatkan apa yang disebut
universal gate set.
Artinya adalah bahwa
operasi uniter apapun pada sejumlah berapa pun qubit bisa
diimplementasikan secara tepat
atau sedekat mungkin
dengan quantum circuit yang dibuat hanya dari gate-gate ini.
Dengan kata lain, ini adalah
set gate yang cukup bagus sehingga kita bisa membangun operasi uniter apapun darinya.
Tidak harus tepat, tapi kita bisa mendapatkan aproksimasi sebaik yang kita inginkan.
Itu mungkin memerlukan banyak gate, dan sebenarnya tidak terlalu sulit untuk berpikir bahwa itu harus memerlukan
banyak gate terkadang,
tapi bagaimanapun, itu selalu mungkin.
Bukan hal yang mudah untuk membuktikan bahwa ini adalah universal gate set meskipun, dan kita tidak akan membahas bagaimana
itu dilakukan dalam seri,
tapi itu adalah fakta yang cukup terkenal dan sebenarnya ada berbagai
cara untuk membuktikannya.
Ada juga set gate lain yang kadang-kadang digunakan
sebagai ganti yang ini, seperti Toffoli gate, Hadamard gate, dan S gate selain pengukuran,
tapi ini adalah pilihan yang cukup standar.
Jadi secara ringkas, ini adalah
operasi kuantum yang akan kita pandang sebagai elementer.
Untuk Boolean circuit,
kita akan mempertimbangkan empat gate ini sebagai
operasi elementer: AND gate, OR gate, NOT gate dan FANOUT.
FANOUT, omong-omong, tidak
selalu dihitung sebagai gate, tapi akan
penting bagi kita untuk melakukan ini seperti yang akan kita lihat nanti dalam pelajaran.
Mirip dengan yang kita miliki untuk
standard quantum gate set kita, set ini sedikit redundan.
Kamu tidak memerlukan AND maupun OR. Kamu bisa membuat salah satunya menggunakan yang lain dengan tiga NOT gate,
tapi tidak ada salahnya memasukkan keduanya dan itu memang mudah.
Seperti yang mungkin sudah kamu ketahui, ini adalah universal gate set
untuk komputasi deterministik, yang berarti bahwa fungsi apapun
dari bit ke bit
bisa diimplementasikan dengan Boolean circuit yang terdiri dari gate-gate dari koleksi ini.
Sekali lagi, sama seperti yang kita miliki
untuk quantum circuit, ini tidak berarti bahwa setiap fungsi bisa diimplementasikan secara efisien
oleh Boolean circuit,
dan memang sebagian besar fungsi
hanya bisa diimplementasikan dengan circuit yang sangat besar
dengan alasan sederhana bahwa ada banyak sekali fungsi
dan semuanya tidak bisa memiliki circuit yang kecil. Tidak ada cukup
circuit kecil untuk semua.
Universalitas lebih mudah
untuk dibuktikan dalam kasus ini daripada dalam kasus kuantum ternyata.
Jadi kalau kamu belum tahu
cara membuktikannya, pikirkan dan
lihat apakah kamu bisa menemukannya jika kamu mau.
Sekarang setelah kita memutuskan
gate yang akan kita izinkan dan yang akan kita pertimbangkan
sebagai operasi elementer, kita bisa berpikir tentang berapa banyak dari mereka
yang diperlukan untuk melakukan
berbagai komputasi.
Untuk melakukan itu, kita akan
menggunakan definisi ini untuk ukuran circuit.
Definisi ini berlaku untuk
Boolean maupun quantum circuit dan sangat sederhana.
Ukuran circuit adalah
total jumlah gate yang dimilikinya.
Misalnya, jika kita kembali
ke contoh yang sama yang telah kita lihat beberapa kali, yaitu Boolean circuit kita untuk menghitung exclusive OR dari dua bit,
kita melihat bahwa ukurannya adalah tujuh
karena ada tujuh gate, dua FANOUT gate, dua NOT gate,
dua AND gate dan satu OR gate. Kalau kita memutuskan untuk tidak menghitung
FANOUT gate, yang umum, ukurannya sama dengan lima,
tapi kita akan menghitung FANOUT gate, jadi ukurannya adalah tujuh.
WEBVTT
Ukuran circuit
sesuai dengan jumlah operasi elementer
yang perlu kita lakukan.
Jadi kalau kita melakukan
operasi-operasi itu secara berurutan, ukurannya akan memberi tahu
kita berapa lama itu akan memakan waktu,
jadi kamu bisa berpikir tentang ukuran circuit sebagai mewakili waktu jalan berurutan.
Ini akan menjadi cara kita
mengukur biaya komputasi untuk tujuan pelajaran ini.
Ada properti lain
dari circuit meskipun yang juga bisa dipandang sebagai jumlah waktu
yang diperlukan untuk menjalankan circuit, dan itu adalah kedalaman circuit.
Tepatnya, kedalaman
adalah jumlah maksimum gate yang ditemui pada jalur manapun dari kabel input ke kabel output,
yang ekuivalen dengan jumlah lapisan gate yang kita butuhkan
untuk membuat circuit, di mana lapisan mengacu pada sekumpulan gate
yang bisa dilakukan secara bersamaan karena mereka tidak memiliki
kabel yang sama.
Misalnya, circuit kita
dari sebelumnya memiliki kedalaman empat, dan kita bisa melihat langsung dari diagram bahwa ada empat lapisan.
FANOUT gate bisa
dilakukan secara bersamaan, NOT gate bisa
dilakukan secara bersamaan dan AND gate bisa
dilakukan secara bersamaan juga.
Jadi kita bisa berpikir tentang kedalaman circuit sebagai mewakili waktu jalan paralel.
Kedalaman circuit tentu merupakan gagasan yang menarik dan penting dan ada beberapa teknik yang sangat
canggih yang bisa digunakan untuk mengurangi
kedalaman yang diperlukan untuk beberapa komputasi, terkadang cukup dramatis, sebenarnya, tapi itu adalah topik lanjutan
dan kita tidak akan terlalu banyak lagi membicarakannya dalam seri ini.
Jadi sekali lagi, kita akan
mengukur biaya komputasi dalam hal ukuran circuit atau dengan kata lain,
jumlah operasi elementer yang diperlukan untuk melakukan komputasi.
Di awal pelajaran, kita berbicara tentang masalah
faktorisasi integer dan kita melihat bahwa waktu yang diperlukan untuk algoritma untuk menyelesaikan masalah ini
bisa meningkat seiring input tumbuh dalam panjang, dan ini biasanya
masalah yang kita fokuskan
ketika kita menganalisis algoritma.
Yaitu, kita tertarik pada bagaimana biaya menjalankan algoritma berkembang seiring input menjadi semakin besar.
Tentu saja, jenis penskalaan ini bukan satu-satunya hal yang penting.
Misalnya, kita mungkin hanya tertarik untuk menemukan faktor
dari RSA1024 dan hanya itu.
Jadi dalam kasus seperti itu, kita akan berbicara tentang
instance masalah tunggal di mana tidak ada yang tumbuh.
Tapi ketika kita berpikir tentang algoritma, cara biaya mereka
berkembang sangat penting dan memberi tahu kita banyak
tentang algoritma.
Sudut pandang ini
konsisten dengan ide bahwa algoritma adalah fundamental, dan seperti yang saya bicarakan sebelumnya,
seiring waktu berjalan dan teknologi berkembang, mereka akan digunakan terhadap
input yang semakin besar.
Tapi perhatikan bahwa sementara input ke masalah komputasi
bisa tumbuh dalam ukuran, circuit tidak tumbuh.
Setiap circuit memiliki ukuran tetap.
Dan untuk alasan itu, jika kita ingin mendeskripsikan
algoritma menggunakan circuit, kita sebenarnya akan membutuhkan keluarga circuit untuk melakukannya,
dan dengan keluarga circuit, kita maksudkan koleksi circuit yang semakin besar sehingga kita bisa mengakomodasi input
seiring mereka menjadi semakin besar. Misalnya, mari kita pertimbangkan algoritma deterministik klasik
untuk masalah faktorisasi integer, mungkin satu yang berbasis pada pembagian percobaan, tapi detail tidak benar-benar penting
untuk tujuan contoh ini.
Kita bisa secara prinsip
mendeskripsikan algoritma semacam itu menggunakan keluarga Boolean circuit di mana jika kita ingin memfaktorkan angka
yang representasi binernya memiliki N-bit, kita mengambil circuit CN dari keluarga kita dan kita memasukkan angka
yang ingin kita faktorkan
ke dalam bit input dari circuit tersebut.
Terkadang kita mungkin memilih untuk memparameterisasi circuit ini
dengan cara yang berbeda, jadi mungkin tidak selalu demikian bahwa circuit ke-N memiliki N bit input,
tapi itu adalah cara yang cukup umum untuk melakukannya. Secara alami, seiring panjang input menjadi lebih panjang, kita akan mengharapkan circuit
dalam keluarga ini untuk menjadi lebih besar
mencerminkan fakta bahwa
memfaktorkan angka empat bit jauh lebih mudah daripada memfaktorkan angka 1.024 bit, misalnya.
Dan jadi, dengan itu dalam pikiran, kita mengukur biaya algoritma semacam itu dengan sebuah fungsi, yang memberi tahu kita berapa banyak
operasi elementer
yang kita butuhkan untuk setiap kemungkinan panjang input, dan kita bisa melakukannya untuk algoritma klasik maupun kuantum.
Sebagai contoh, mari kita pertimbangkan masalah penjumlahan integer, yang tentu jauh
lebih sederhana daripada faktorisasi
atau bahkan menghitung GCD.
Demi menjaga hal-hal sederhana, misalkan N dan
M keduanya adalah integer non-negatif dan mereka direpresentasikan
oleh string biner dengan panjang yang sama.
Bagaimana kita mungkin membangun Boolean circuit yang menjumlahkan dua angka ini bersama?
Baik, mari kita mulai dengan algoritma, algoritma standar untuk penjumlahan, yang merupakan analog basis dua dari metode
yang saya asumsikan kita semua pelajari untuk menjumlahkan angka dengan
pensil dan selembar kertas, jadi kita mulai dengan
bit paling tidak signifikan,
menjumlahkannya bersama, dan itu memberi kita bit
paling tidak signifikan dari hasil bersama dengan bit carry
yang harus kita pertimbangkan
saat kita pindah ke posisi berikutnya. Dan kita terus bergerak melalui bit, menghasilkan bit output
bersama dengan bit carry
sampai kita mencapai akhir.
WEBVTT
Metode ini bisa
dinyatakan cukup langsung dalam hal Boolean circuit.
Satu cara untuk memikirkannya adalah dengan mulai dengan circuit kecil untuk menjumlahkan dua integer bit tunggal bersama.
Itu akan memberi kita angka
antara nol dan dua, di mana bit yang kurang signifikan adalah XOR dari bit input
dan bit yang lebih signifikan, atau bit carry jika kamu mau, adalah AND dari dua bit input.
Terkadang kita menyebut circuit yang melakukan
dua operasi ini bersama sebagai half adder.
Itu bekerja dengan baik ketika hanya ada dua bit input, tapi jika kita ingin menjumlahkan integer dengan lebih dari hanya satu bit masing-masing,
kita akan perlu menangani
bit carry dengan cara tertentu.
Jadi yang bisa kita lakukan adalah menggabungkan
dua half adder bersama dan mengambil OR dari
bit carry yang mereka hasilkan untuk membuat apa yang disebut full adder,
yang pada dasarnya adalah Boolean circuit untuk menjumlahkan tiga angka
bit tunggal bersama.
Dan setelah kita memiliki full adder, kita bisa menjumlahkan angka bersama
hanya dengan menggabungkan, melanjutkan dari bit paling tidak signifikan
ke bit paling signifikan. Kita pada dasarnya hanya mengimplementasikan algoritma penjumlahan standar menggunakan full adder untuk
menangani bit carry.
Jadi berapa biaya komputasi ini?
Baik, kita membutuhkan tujuh gate elementer
untuk setiap XOR gate, yang berarti 10 gate untuk half adder
dan oleh karena itu 21 gate untuk full adder, yaitu dua half adder ditambah satu OR gate.
Jadi pada akhirnya, jika angka input kita keduanya memiliki AND bit, kita membutuhkan half adder untuk
bit paling tidak signifikan
dan full adder untuk setiap bit lainnya, dan hasil akhirnya adalah 21 kali N dikurangi satu ditambah 10 atau 21 N dikurangi 11 gate secara total.
Kalau kita memutuskan karena alasan tertentu bahwa kita tidak ingin
menghitung FANOUT gate dan kita memasukkan XOR
gate dalam set gate kita, kita akan membutuhkan lima N dikurangi
tiga gate secara total.
Bagus untuk tahu persis berapa banyak gate atau operasi elementer yang diperlukan untuk melakukan komputasi yang berbeda,
seperti yang baru saja kita lihat dengan penjumlahan integer.
Dan tentu saja, jika kita benar-benar ingin mengimplementasikan komputasi ini, kita perlu mengetahui detail ini.
Tapi kalau kita selalu mendalami detail sebanyak ini, terutama untuk
algoritma yang lebih rumit, kita akan dengan cepat terkubur dalam detail
yang dalam banyak kasus memiliki
kepentingan sekunder.
Satu cara untuk menyederhanakan masalah yang sangat umum dalam
analisis algoritma adalah dengan menggunakan notasi big-O,
yang memungkinkan kita untuk mengekspresikan
dan membandingkan laju pertumbuhan dengan cara yang cukup sederhana
yang sangat nyaman.
Dan di sini kamu bisa melihat definisi yang mendasari notasi ini.
Misalkan kita punya
dua fungsi G dan H, yang bisa kita pikirkan sebagai mengambil nilai integer
non-negatif untuk kesederhanaan,
meskipun itu sebenarnya tidak diperlukan. Mungkin G dan H mewakili biaya komputasi yang berbeda, misalnya.
Kita kemudian mengatakan bahwa G adalah big-O dari H, yang secara tradisional ditulis
dengan tanda sama dengan seperti ini.
Jika G dari N paling banyak
beberapa konstanta positif C kali H dari N, selama N cukup besar.
Jadi ini tentang apa yang
terjadi ketika N menjadi besar.
Secara formal, apa artinya cukup besar adalah bahwa ada beberapa pilihan N nol sehingga pertidaksamaan benar
setiap kali N setidaknya N nol.
Kuncinya di sini adalah bahwa
angka-angka C dan N nol ini tetap.
Mereka bisa berupa angka apapun,
tapi apapun itu, mereka tidak bisa berubah seiring N tumbuh.
Jika kamu belum pernah melihat
definisi semacam ini sebelumnya, mungkin butuh waktu untuk membiasakan diri dan kamu bisa menemukan sumber daya
yang akan menjelaskan konsep ini
secara jauh lebih detail
daripada yang bisa saya lakukan dalam pelajaran ini.
Biasanya yang kita lakukan adalah memilih
fungsi H agar sederhana untuk mengekspresikan sesuatu tentang seberapa cepat fungsi G tumbuh.
Misalnya, fungsi yang nilainya adalah 17 kali N kubik dikurangi 257
kali N kuadrat ditambah
65.537 adalah big-O dari N kubik, dan kamu bisa menyesuaikan contoh ini dengan definisi
dengan memilih C dan N nol dengan tepat.
Misalnya, jika kita mengambil C sama dengan 18, maka kita akan memiliki bahwa
ekspresi memang paling banyak 18 kali N kubik
selama N cukup besar.
Menghubungkan notasi ini kembali ke
contoh penjumlahan integer, apa yang sekarang bisa kita katakan adalah bahwa ada keluarga Boolean circuit
untuk menjumlahkan integer non-negatif bersama sehingga ukuran circuit ke-N, yaitu yang bekerja
untuk input dengan panjang N
adalah big-O dari N. Ukuran sebenarnya dari CN
menurut analisis kita adalah 21 kali N dikurangi 11,
tapi itu big-O dari N.
Sekarang tidak selalu pintar untuk membuang detail seperti ini, tapi di sini masuk akal
karena itu mengungkapkan sifat esensial dari algoritma penjumlahan standar, yaitu biayanya berkembang secara linier
dalam ukuran angka
yang kita jumlahkan bersama, dan ekspresi ini tidak sensitif terhadap beberapa detail tingkat rendah dari model kita,
seperti tepat gate mana yang kita anggap sebagai operasi elementer.
Misalnya, jika kita memutuskan bahwa XOR gate harus dianggap sebagai
operasi elementer atau bahwa FANOUT gate tidak
boleh dihitung sebagai gate atau keduanya,
kita tetap akan memiliki bahwa penjumlahan integer bisa dihitung dengan biaya big-O dari N.
WEBVTT
Berikut adalah contoh lain dari
masalah komputasi, perkalian integer.
Mirip dengan penjumlahan, kita bisa bertanya apa biaya
komputasi ini.
Jika kita mempertimbangkan algoritma
perkalian standar, yang berarti analog basis dua dari metode perkalian angka
yang diajarkan di sekolah dasar,
yang pada dasarnya hanya
menggeser dan menjumlahkan ketika kita bekerja dengan angka dalam biner, kita menemukan bahwa ada Boolean circuit yang berukuran big-O dari N kuadrat
untuk mengalikan integer N-bit.
Saya tidak akan membahasnya secara detail. Tentu saja circuit-nya sedikit
lebih rumit daripada yang untuk penjumlahan, tapi kalau kamu berpikir tentang cara
algoritma perkalian standar
bekerja, itu tidak mengherankan.
Pada dasarnya, kita perlu
melakukan kira-kira N penjumlahan, masing-masing yang memiliki biaya linier, dan jadi kita mendapatkan
biaya kuadrat secara keseluruhan.
Ini bisa digeneralisasi. Jika salah satu angka memiliki N bit dan yang lainnya memiliki N bit, maka kita membutuhkan circuit dengan
ukuran big-O dari N kali M.
Di sini, omong-omong, kita sebenarnya menggunakan ekstensi dari notasi big-O di mana kita memiliki beberapa variabel, tapi bisa diperluas seperti ini,
dan kalau kamu tertarik
dengan detail spesifiknya, saya akan merujukmu ke konten buku teks
untuk pelajaran, yang sekali lagi ditautkan dalam
deskripsi video.
Sebenarnya mungkin
untuk mengalikan dua integer N-bit dengan cara
yang secara asimtotik lebih unggul dari algoritma perkalian standar.
Khususnya, algoritma perkalian Schonhage-Strassen
mengalikan dua integer N-bit dengan biaya big-O dari
N kali panjang N
kali panjang dari panjang N. Jadi seiring N menjadi besar, seperti
puluhan ribu bit,
ini sebenarnya cara yang lebih
efisien untuk mengalikan, tapi itu rumit dan overhead membuatnya tidak praktis
untuk angka yang lebih kecil.
Jadi mari kita tambahkan perkalian
ke daftar contoh kita.
Dan demi kesederhanaan, mari kita cantumkan biaya yang diberikan oleh algoritma perkalian standar, yaitu big-O dari N kuadrat.
Jadi sekali lagi, kita berfokus pada sifat esensial dari biaya ini, yaitu berkembang secara kuadrat
atau sub kuadrat jika kita menggunakan metode yang secara asimtotik lebih unggul.
Kita juga bisa mempertimbangkan
masalah pembagian integer, yang dinyatakan secara tepat di layar.
Di sini kita berbicara tentang menghitung quotient dan remainder, jadi jawabannya terdiri
dari dua integer, Q dan R.
Sekali lagi, ada algoritma standar
untuk pembagian dan itu juga memiliki biaya kuadrat dan seperti perkalian,
sebenarnya ada
algoritma yang secara asimtotik lebih unggul.
Jadi bagaimana algoritma GCD dibandingkan?
Baik, algoritma Euclid ternyata
memiliki biaya kuadrat, dan itulah yang saya maksudkan
sebelumnya dalam pelajaran ketika saya mengatakan bahwa kita bisa menghitung GCD
dengan biaya yang kira-kira sama dengan mengalikan dua angka bersama.
Sekali lagi, ada
algoritma yang secara asimtotik lebih unggul sejalan dengan
penjumlahan dan perkalian,
meskipun biayanya sedikit
lebih tinggi dalam kasus ini, setidaknya sejauh yang kita ketahui.
Saya akan menyebutkan hanya satu contoh lagi dari masalah yang akan ditambahkan ke daftar ini, dan itu adalah eksponen modular.
Di sini ada tiga angka
input, K, M, dan N, dan tujuannya adalah untuk menghitung
N pangkat K modulo-M,
yang berarti sisa
setelah kita membagi dengan M.
Sama sekali tidak jelas, tapi kita bisa menghitung
eksponen modular dengan biaya qubit, yang berarti big-O dari N kubik
untuk integer N-bit.
Cara untuk melakukan yang satu ini bukan dengan pertama menghitung N pangkat K dan kemudian menghitung sisanya.
Bahkan menuliskan N pangkat K bisa memerlukan bit secara eksponensial, jadi pendekatan itu tidak akan berhasil.
Sebaliknya, kita bisa menggunakan algoritma
yang disebut algoritma pangkat, yang juga disebut repeated squaring di mana semuanya dilakukan modulo-M
dan kita menggunakan bit dari
K untuk secara iteratif mengkuadratkan dan mengalikan dengan cara
yang membuat semuanya berhasil.
Jadi yang satu ini lebih
mahal daripada yang lainnya, tapi kita masih bisa melakukan
eksponen modular dengan cukup cepat pada angka
dengan ribuan bit.
Jadi bagaimana biaya dari tugas-tugas ini dibandingkan dengan faktorisasi integer?
Jika kita mulai dari yang sederhana dan
berpikir tentang pembagian percobaan di mana kita pertama memeriksa apakah dua adalah faktor dari angka input
dan kemudian memeriksa tiga dan seterusnya, kita akan mendapatkan algoritma yang cukup
mahal, big-O dari N kuadrat kali
dua pangkat N dibagi dua.
Setiap pembagian membutuhkan waktu kuadrat dan dalam kasus terburuk, kita akan perlu mencari faktor prima hingga akar kuadrat dari angka input,
dan itulah dari mana N
dibagi dua berasal. Kalau kita belum menemukan
faktor prima pada saat itu, kita bisa berhenti karena kemudian
angka input itu sendiri harus prima.
Ini sangat mahal karena N muncul sebagai eksponen dalam ekspresi ini, yang berarti bahwa
algoritma ini memiliki biaya eksponensial.
Sebaliknya, semua contoh yang kita miliki dalam kotak ini memiliki apa yang kita sebut biaya polinomial di mana N dinaikkan ke suatu pangkat,
tapi pangkat itu selalu berupa angka tetap yang tidak tumbuh seiring
panjang input tumbuh.
Dalam kasus-kasus ini, pangkatnya
adalah satu, dua, dan tiga.
Saya akan kembali ke biaya polinomial versus eksponensial dalam sesaat, tapi pertama, mari kita selesaikan
apa yang kita ketahui tentang faktorisasi.
WEBVTT
Sebelumnya saya menyebutkan
number field sieve, yang merupakan algoritma faktorisasi terbaik yang kita miliki dalam hal cara biayanya berkembang.
Sebenarnya, biaya algoritma ini tidak dibuktikan secara ketat karena terhubung dengan beberapa pertanyaan terbuka tentang teori bilangan,
tapi diperkirakan memiliki
biaya yang terlihat seperti ini.
Kali ini big-O ada di eksponen, tapi saya akan menyapu
detail itu di bawah karpet.
Poin utamanya adalah bahwa itu secara signifikan lebih baik
daripada pembagian percobaan karena meskipun N memang
muncul di eksponen,
itu dinaikkan ke pangkat 1/3 dan itu diterjemahkan ke biaya yang jauh lebih rendah dan itulah mengapa algoritma ini
bisa menangani angka seperti RSA250, sedangkan pembagian percobaan
jelas tidak bisa.
Ini masih eksponensial meskipun dalam arti bahwa pangkat N muncul dalam eksponen, dan jadi, sebagai hasilnya,
itu masih tidak bisa menangani
angka seperti RSA1024.
Sekarang izinkan saya mengatakan sedikit lebih banyak tentang biaya polinomial
versus biaya eksponensial.
Kita katakan bahwa sebuah algoritma
memiliki biaya polinomial jika biayanya adalah big-O dari N pangkat B,
di mana B bisa berupa angka positif apapun, tapi kuncinya adalah bahwa B harus tetap, yang berarti tidak berubah
seiring panjang input N tumbuh.
Untuk contoh yang kita lihat tadi, yaitu penjumlahan integer, perkalian, pembagian, menghitung GCD
dan eksponen modular,
kita punya bahwa B adalah
satu, dua atau tiga.
Jadi ini semuanya adalah
algoritma biaya polinomial.
Tapi ketika kita mengatakan biaya polinomial
secara lebih umum, B bisa berupa angka positif apapun.
Bahkan bisa satu juta,
tapi harus tetap.
Sebagai abstraksi yang sangat kasar, algoritma yang memiliki biaya polinomial biasanya dipandang sebagai mewakili algoritma yang efisien.
Itu jelas penyederhanaan berlebihan, tapi sebagai panduan kasar, kamu bisa berpikir tentang
algoritma biaya polinomial
sebagai entah bagaimana memanfaatkan
struktur masalah untuk membangun solusi sebagai lawan dari pendekatan
brute force
atau pencarian exhaustive
atas ruang yang sangat besar.
Tentu saja, algoritma yang biayanya berkembang sebagai N pangkat satu juta
pada input dengan panjang N
tidak secara wajar
dipandang sebagai efisien, dan kita tidak akan berharap bisa
menjalankannya pada input yang besar.
Tapi tetap saja bahkan algoritma N pangkat
satu juta harus melakukan sesuatu yang cerdas yang entah bagaimana mencerminkan struktur
dari masalah apapun yang diselesaikannya untuk menghindari penskalaan eksponensial dalam biaya yang akan dikaitkan dengan
pencarian exhaustive atas domain yang besar.
Dan dalam praktik, identifikasi algoritma biaya polinomial sebenarnya hanyalah langkah pertama
menuju efisiensi.
Jika sebuah masalah penting
dan seseorang menemukan
algoritma biaya polinomial pertama
untuknya, mungkin dengan eksponen yang sangat besar,
kamu bisa cukup yakin bahwa desainer algoritma
akan menemukan peningkatan yang menyebabkan eksponen itu turun.
Pada dasarnya, kamu bisa
berpikir tentang keberadaan algoritma biaya polinomial untuk masalah sebagai mendemonstrasikan kelayakan
pemecahan masalah tersebut
pada input yang cukup besar, tapi masih bisa ada banyak pekerjaan yang diperlukan untuk mencapai efisiensi yang sesungguhnya.
Dalam teori kompleksitas, adalah umum untuk mengatakan bahwa biaya algoritma
berkembang sub-eksponensial jika biayanya adalah big-O dari dua pangkat N
pangkat epsilon untuk setiap bilangan real positif epsilon, dan jika tidak sub-eksponensial,
maka eksponensial, atau bahkan bisa super-eksponensial seperti dua pangkat dua pangkat N,
yang secara dobel eksponensial,
tapi selama output
tidak super-eksponensial panjangnya, setiap masalah sebenarnya bisa
dihitung oleh Boolean circuit
yang memiliki biaya eksponensial ternyata. Jadi perbedaan penting di sini adalah antara biaya polinomial
dan eksponensial.
Kita tidak mengetahui algoritma klasik biaya sub-eksponensial untuk
faktorisasi integer.
Misalnya, biaya number field sieve bukan big-O dari dua pangkat
N pangkat epsilon ketika epsilon adalah 1/3 atau kurang,
jadi itu tidak memenuhi definisi ini.
Itu jelas merupakan algoritma yang sangat cerdas, tapi itu masih sebuah sieve dan kita masih secara efektif mencari
atas ruang yang sangat besar untuk mengidentifikasi faktor dari angka yang diberikan.
Seperti yang akan kita lihat di pelajaran berikutnya, sebenarnya ada algoritma kuantum biaya polinomial
untuk faktorisasi integer.
Algoritma Shor memiliki biaya polinomial dan khususnya memiliki biaya qubit, mirip dengan eksponen modular.
Kelas masalah lain yang
mungkin kamu kenal adalah kelas masalah NP-complete.
Saya tidak akan membahas apa itu masalah NP-complete dalam pelajaran ini, tapi kamu bisa mencarinya
jika kamu tertarik.
Diperkirakan bahwa
tidak satupun dari masalah-masalah ini memiliki biaya sub-eksponensial.
Itu pada dasarnya adalah versi berbasis circuit dari apa yang kadang-kadang disebut
hipotesis waktu eksponensial, tapi sejauh ini tidak ada yang bisa
membuktikannya.
Faktanya, kita bahkan tidak bisa membuktikan bahwa tidak ada algoritma biaya linier untuk masalah NP-complete.
Itu hanya sangat sulit, setidaknya
sejauh yang kita ketahui, untuk menyingkirkan kemungkinan
penemuan masa depan dari algoritma yang sangat kreatif
untuk masalah-masalah ini.
WEBVTT
Berikut adalah gambar yang
mengilustrasikan hubungan antara biaya polinomial dan eksponensial.
Pada sumbu X, kita memiliki panjang input dari masalah apapun yang kita pikirkan, dan sumbu Y mewakili
biaya memecahkan masalah tersebut
atau kamu bisa berpikir tentang
itu sebagai waktu yang diperlukan untuk memecahkan masalah jika kamu mau.
Algoritma biaya eksponensial
mungkin berkembang seperti ini.
Untuk input yang pendek, biayanya mungkin tidak terlalu tinggi, seperti memfaktorkan
angka 12, misalnya,
tapi seiring panjang input menjadi lebih panjang, biayanya pada akhirnya akan meledak.
Algoritma biaya polinomial,
di sisi lain, mungkin memiliki penskalaan yang terlihat seperti ini.
Biayanya akan tetap meningkat secara umum seiring input menjadi lebih panjang, dan mungkin bahkan lebih mahal dari algoritma biaya eksponensial
untuk beberapa input,
tapi pada akhirnya akan
jauh lebih murah daripada algoritma biaya eksponensial dan tidak meledak
dengan cara yang ekstrem yang sama
yang dilakukan algoritma biaya eksponensial.
Jadi jika kita bayangkan bahwa kita
memiliki beberapa biaya maksimum yang bersedia kita keluarkan, atau jumlah maksimum waktu yang bersedia kita tunggu untuk jawaban,
jika kamu mau berpikir tentang waktu, maka algoritma biaya eksponensial hanya akan bekerja untuk input
hingga panjang tertentu,
sedangkan, secara umum, algoritma biaya polinomial akan memungkinkan kita untuk memecahkan
masalah untuk input yang lebih besar.
Dan itulah mengapa, misalnya, kita bisa dengan mudah menghitung GCD untuk angka dengan ribuan bit, tapi dalam kasus terburuk,
kita tidak bisa memfaktorkan angka seukuran ini.
Di bagian terakhir pelajaran, kita akan mengalihkan perhatian kita untuk mengimplementasikan komputasi klasik
pada komputer kuantum.
Lebih tepatnya, kita akan
melihat bahwa komputasi apapun yang bisa dilakukan oleh Boolean circuit juga bisa dilakukan oleh quantum circuit
dengan biaya yang kira-kira sama. Terlebih lagi, ini bisa
dilakukan dengan cara yang bersih yang penting jika kita ingin
menjalankan komputasi ini
sebagai subrutin di dalam
komputasi kuantum yang lebih besar, dan saya akan menjelaskan apa yang saya maksud dengan bersih ketika kita lebih jauh dalam diskusi.
Kita akan menggunakan
Toffoli gate dalam proses ini.
Ingat bahwa Toffoli gate adalah controlled-controlled-NOT gate, jadi tindakannya pada state basis standar
adalah seperti yang kamu lihat di sini di layar.
Perhatikan bahwa kita juga bisa
berpikir tentang Toffoli gate sebagai query gate
untuk fungsi AND.
Itu bukan berarti bahwa mereka adalah query gate dalam arti literal. Seperti yang saya sebutkan di awal pelajaran, kita tidak bekerja dalam
model query saat ini,
melainkan, tindakannya mengikuti pola yang sama sebagai query gate.
Kita bisa memikirkan nilai biner A dan B sebagai input untuk fungsi AND dan seperti query gate,
nilai-nilai ini di-echo
sebagai bagian dari output dan nilai fungsi, yang berarti AND logika dari A dan B
di-XOR ke qubit paling bawah. Sekarang, kita belum memasukkan Toffoli gate dalam standard gate set kita.
Kita bisa mengubah pikiran jika kita mau, tapi kita tidak perlu
melakukannya karena sebagai alternatif, kita bisa mengimplementasikan Toffoli
gate menggunakan Hadamard gate,
T dan T dagger gate
dan controlled NOT gate seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Sama sekali tidak jelas
bahwa circuit tertentu ini mengimplementasikan Toffoli gate, tapi memang begitu, dan kamu bisa percaya saja kata saya
atau kalikan semuanya sendiri untuk mendapatkan latihan tambahan, atau kamu bisa bertanya kepada Qiskit atau Python
atau perangkat lunak apapun yang mengalikan matriks untuk melakukan perkalian untukmu.
Dan kamu bisa melihat
konten buku teks untuk pelajaran untuk melihat ini dilakukan menggunakan Qiskit.
Sekarang kita bisa melanjutkan untuk mensimulasikan Boolean gate dengan quantum circuit dan semua yang kita butuhkan untuk
melakukan ini adalah NOT gate,
controlled NOT gate dan Toffoli gate.
Operasi-operasi ini semuanya deterministik selain bersifat uniter dan terkadang kita mendeskripsikan
operasi seperti ini sebagai reversibel, dan sebenarnya,
studi tentang komputasi reversibel mendahului komputasi kuantum dan itulah dari mana seluruh
prosedur ini sebenarnya berasal.
Boolean gate yang perlu kita
khawatirkan adalah NOT gate, Hadamard gate dan FANOUT gate,
Dan yang akan kita tunjukkan adalah bahwa kita bisa mengimplementasikan gate-gate ini, atau mensimulasikannya jika kamu mau, menggunakan NOT gate,
controlled NOT gate dan Toffoli gate.
Supaya jelas, yang kita inginkan adalah quantum circuit yang memungkinkan kita untuk menghitung nilai Boolean gate yang baru saja saya sebutkan
ketika kita memberi mereka qubit dalam
state basis standar sebagai input.
Untuk input state kuantum arbitrer, tindakannya akan ditentukan
oleh linieritas seperti biasa.
Kita tidak perlu melakukan apapun yang
khusus dengan NOT gate. NOT gate adalah NOT gate dan bisa diimplementasikan langsung.
Dan OR gate bisa disimulasikan
menggunakan Toffoli dan NOT gate.
AND gate itu mudah, terutama mengingat apa yang baru saja saya katakan beberapa saat lalu tentang Toffoli gate yang pada dasarnya adalah
implementasi query gate
dari fungsi AND.
Tepatnya, yang bisa kita lakukan adalah memperkenalkan qubit baru yang diinisialisasi ke state nol
dan biarkan qubit itu menjadi
target dari Toffoli gate kita dan biarkan dua qubit input menjadi kontrol.
Nama-nama yang berbeda diberikan
untuk qubit ekstra seperti ini, yang sering diperkenalkan
ke dalam komputasi kuantum dan saya akan menyebutnya workspace
qubit hanya untuk memilih nama.
WEBVTT
Asumsi umum kita pada workspace qubit adalah bahwa mereka dimulai dalam state nol dan kita sering bisa mengembalikan
mereka ke state nol
ketika kita selesai dengan mereka, tapi tidak selalu.
Dalam diagram kita memiliki ket nol di dalam persegi panjang bertitik untuk menunjukkan bahwa
inisialisasi qubit ini
adalah bagian dari proses, dan jika kamu tidak memiliki
qubit segar seperti ini, kamu tidak akan bisa
melakukan simulasi ini.
Qubit output paling bawah
adalah yang kita pedulikan karena itulah hasil
dari operasi AND dan kita pada dasarnya
selesai dengan dua lainnya
sehingga mereka bisa tetap di dalam kotak.
Bahkan, kamu bisa membayangkan bahwa menyingkirkan dua qubit ini adalah bagian dari pekerjaan
mensimulasikan AND gate ini,
semacam sampah yang
perlu dibersihkan.
Tapi bagaimanapun, itulah cara kita
bisa mensimulasikan AND gate.
Sekarang kita tahu cara melakukan AND gate, kita bisa melakukan OR gate menggunakan
salah satu hukum De Morgan.
Jika kamu menempatkan NOT gate pada dua input dan output dari AND
gate, kamu akan mendapatkan OR gate, jadi sesederhana itu.
Dan yang terakhir adalah FANOUT, dan untuk yang satu ini, semua yang
kita butuhkan adalah controlled NOT gate bersama dengan workspace qubit.
Khususnya, jika kita
menetapkan workspace qubit sebagai target, kita secara efektif hanya menyalin state basis standar apapun yang masuk,
sehingga itu bertindak seperti FANOUT gate.
Jadi kita punya semua gate kita.
Dan sekarang setelah kita punya semua gate kita, kita bisa melanjutkan ke circuit.
Misalkan kita punya
beberapa Boolean circuit bernama C, dan ini bisa berupa Boolean circuit apapun yang kamu pilih
selama itu terdiri dari
AND atau NOT dan FANOUT gate.
Kita akan membiarkan T menjadi jumlah gate dalam C dan kita akan memberikan nama F untuk fungsi apapun yang dihitung C.
Jadi kita bisa memikirkan F sebagai memiliki bentuk yang kamu lihat di sini, di mana N adalah jumlah bit input dari C,
M adalah jumlah bit output dan sigma adalah alfabet biner.
Dan yang kita lakukan adalah hanya melalui gate-gate C satu per satu.
Kita membiarkan NOT gate sendiri dan kita mengganti yang lainnya dengan simulasi
yang baru saja saya deskripsikan.
Jadi jika C terlihat seperti ini, maka yang kita dapatkan adalah circuit
R yang terlihat seperti ini.
Dalam diagram ini, semua
workspace qubit yang kita butuhkan untuk simulasi telah dikeluarkan dari kotak mereka dan dikumpulkan di bagian bawah.
Jadi K adalah total jumlah
workspace qubit yang kita butuhkan, yaitu satu untuk setiap gate dari C kecuali NOT gate.
Untuk output dari R, kita memiliki qubit yang
sesuai dengan output dari C, dan di sini qubit-qubit tersebut
digambarkan di bagian atas,
meskipun pada akhirnya tidak akan
penting apakah mereka di atas atau tidak.
Tepatnya, dengan asumsi bahwa kita telah menjalankan R pada state basis standar yang sesuai dengan
string N-bit arbitrer X,
M qubit output ini akan berada dalam state basis standar
yang sesuai dengan F dari X.
Kita juga memiliki semua qubit sisa dari AND dan OR gate.
Kita masih perlu memperhitungkan mereka, dan jika kita mengumpulkan semuanya bersama, mereka akan berada dalam beberapa state basis standar.
Apapun state basis standarnya harus merupakan beberapa fungsi dari string X, dan kita akan memberikan
nama G untuk fungsi tersebut.
Jadi G adalah fungsi baru yang
ditentukan oleh gate-gate C yang memberi tahu kita state
dari qubit sisa ini
setelah R dijalankan. G adalah huruf berikutnya setelah F, jadi itu adalah satu alasan untuk
menyebut fungsi ini G,
tapi alasan lain untuk menyebutnya G adalah karena G adalah singkatan dari garbage (sampah).
Ini semua adalah garbage qubit, dan khususnya, kita
memiliki dua garbage qubit untuk setiap AND gate dan untuk setiap OR gate.
Total jumlah gate
yang kita butuhkan adalah big-O dari T.
Itu karena untuk setiap gate dari C, kita membutuhkan sejumlah terbatas quantum gate.
OR gate adalah yang paling mahal. Untuk itu, kita membutuhkan tiga NOT gate bersama dengan satu Toffoli gate,
dan Toffoli gate membutuhkan 15 gate dari standard gate set kita.
Jadi itu paling banyak 18 gate
dalam R untuk setiap gate dari C.
Jika kamu ingin mengoptimalkan ini, kamu bisa, tapi untuk tujuan
analisis asimtotik kasar, kita bisa hanya mengatakan bahwa
R memiliki big-O dari T gate.
Jadi kita berhasil
menghitung fungsi yang sama F yang dihitung Boolean circuit asli C,
dan kita melakukan ini dengan biaya yang linier dalam ukuran C.
Jika yang kita pedulikan hanyalah
menghitung fungsi F ini, maka kita selesai.
Tapi sayangnya, kita memiliki
garbage qubit ini dan garbage qubit ini
umumnya akan merusak
pola interferensi yang membuat algoritma kuantum bekerja jika kita mencoba menggunakan circuit R ini sebagai subrutin
di dalam algoritma kuantum yang lebih besar.
Tapi kita sebenarnya bisa
menyingkirkan sampah ini, dan cara kita bisa melakukannya adalah dengan memanfaatkan fakta bahwa circuit R bisa dibalik,
WEBVTT
atau dengan kata lain, kita
bisa menjalankannya secara terbalik.
Untuk mengilustrasikan cara kerjanya, mari kita bayangkan bahwa kita pertama menjalankan R dan kemudian kita menjalankan R secara terbalik,
yang bisa kita ekspresikan sebagai R dagger.
Supaya jelas tentang ini, artinya adalah bahwa kita menerapkan gate-gate
dari R dalam urutan terbalik dan kita mengambil invers
dari setiap gate.
NOT gate, controlled NOT gate
dan Toffoli gate sebenarnya adalah invers dari diri mereka sendiri, jadi jika kita berpikir dalam
hal gate-gate ini,
maka R dagger sebenarnya hanyalah R dengan gate-gate yang diberikan
dalam urutan terbalik.
Tapi secara umum, kita selalu bisa menjalankan quantum circuit uniter apapun secara terbalik dengan cara yang baru saja saya deskripsikan,
yang berarti bahwa kita menerapkan
gate dalam urutan terbalik dan kita mengganti setiap
gate individual dengan inversnya.
Kalau kita melakukan ini, kita akan menemukan bahwa pertama menjalankan R dan kemudian menjalankan R secara
terbalik tidak melakukan apa pun sama sekali.
Jadi jika kita mulai dalam state basis standar seperti yang kita miliki di sini, maka kita akan berakhir di state basis standar yang persis sama.
Tentu saja, hanya melakukan
itu tidak terlalu membantu, tapi yang bisa kita lakukan adalah kita bisa memperkenalkan sekumpulan qubit ekstra dan khususnya,
ini adalah M qubit di mana M adalah jumlah bit output dari circuit C.
Qubit tambahan ini bisa
dalam state kuantum apapun, tapi untuk menjelaskan cara kerjanya, kita akan mengasumsikan bahwa mereka berada dalam state basis standar
yang sesuai dengan beberapa string Y. Jadi Y adalah string M-bit, dan yang bisa kita lakukan adalah melakukan
sekumpulan controlled NOT gate
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini, yang secara efektif meng-XOR string F dari X
ke string Y yang tersimpan
dalam M qubit bawah ini.
Dan jadi output dari
seluruh komputasi adalah seperti yang muncul di layar.
X dan Y adalah string biner arbitrer. X memiliki M-bit dan Y memiliki M-bit, dan kita juga membutuhkan K workspace qubit.
Ketika kita menjalankan R, kita menghitung F dari X dan string tersebut disimpan
dalam M qubit teratas, tapi kita juga memiliki sekumpulan garbage qubit,
jadi kita meng-XOR output F dari
X ke M qubit bawah dan kemudian menjalankan R secara terbalik
untuk membersihkan sampah.
Perlu saya tunjukkan bahwa penting bahwa R bersifat deterministik.
Jika M qubit teratas ini bisa berada dalam superposisi dari state basis standar, ini tidak akan bekerja dengan benar,
tapi ini bekerja ketika
R bersifat deterministik.
Jadi jika kita membandingkan quantum circuit yang baru saja kita buat dengan Boolean circuit asli C, kita melihat bahwa itu pada dasarnya
bekerja dengan cara yang sama
seperti query gate bekerja
untuk fungsi arbitrer.
Ada perbedaan di sini, yaitu bahwa kita membutuhkan
workspace qubit ini agar semuanya bekerja, tapi jika tidak, kita telah
secara efektif membangun query gate
atau query circuit untuk fungsi apapun yang dihitung C.
Kita juga berhasil, omong-omong, mengembalikan workspace
qubit ke state awalnya, sehingga mereka bisa secara prinsip digunakan kembali
sebagai workspace qubit untuk
komputasi berikutnya.
Kalau kita mau, kita bisa meletakkan kotak di sekitar seluruh quantum circuit dan menyebutnya Q dan hubungannya dengan
C menjadi lebih jelas.
Circuit Q akan
lebih besar dari C secara umum. Kita membutuhkan segelintir quantum gate
dalam Q untuk setiap gate dari C,
dan kita juga membutuhkan controlled NOT gate di tengah, tapi jumlahnya tetap
linier dalam ukuran C.
Perlu juga dicatat bahwa ini adalah prosedur yang sepenuhnya umum yang bekerja untuk Boolean circuit apapun, dan kita tidak mencoba sama sekali untuk mengoptimalkan Q.
Untuk circuit C tertentu, mungkin ada
cara untuk mengurangi ukuran Q, dan itu termasuk menggunakan metode
yang mengurangi jumlah
workspace qubit yang dibutuhkan jika itu adalah sesuatu
yang ingin kita lakukan, dan itulah prosedur untuk menjalankan
komputasi klasik
pada komputer kuantum.
Cukup sederhana, tapi itu adalah hal yang penting
untuk bisa dilakukan.
Khususnya, sekarang setelah
kita tahu cara melakukan ini, kita bebas untuk menggunakan komputasi klasik apapun yang kita inginkan
di dalam komputasi kuantum, dengan syarat bahwa kita mengikuti form ini di mana input di-echo dan output di-XOR
ke sekumpulan qubit
sama seperti yang kita miliki untuk query gate.
Biayanya berkembang secara linier. Jadi misalnya, kita bisa
membuat quantum circuit untuk masalah seperti penjumlahan integer,
perkalian, pembagian, menghitung GCD dan eksponen modular, dan ini semua bisa dilakukan dengan biaya asimtotik yang sama
seperti untuk Boolean circuit.
Kita membutuhkan workspace qubit untuk melakukan ini, tapi setidaknya mereka tersedia untuk digunakan kembali ketika
kita selesai dengan mereka.
Satu catatan akhir yang layak disebutkan adalah bahwa metode ini memberi kita metode untuk mengimplementasikan query gate,
yang saya singgung di pelajaran sebelumnya.
Yaitu, jika kita memiliki algoritma query yang mengambil beberapa fungsi F sebagai input, dan kita memiliki cara untuk menghitung
F dengan Boolean circuit,
maka kita bisa mengikuti prosedur ini untuk membangun query gate untuk fungsi tersebut dan kemudian menjalankan algoritma query kita padanya.
Apakah itu berguna atau tidak bergantung pada masalah query itu sendiri dan apa yang kita coba capai, tapi pada dasarnya, konstruksi ini memberi kita
cara untuk menghubungkan model query ke model komputasi yang lebih standar.
Ini dalam beberapa hal adalah bagaimana algoritma Shor untuk faktorisasi integer bekerja.
WEBVTT
Kita akan membangun
quantum circuit seperti ini dari beberapa operasi aritmetika yang kita bahas sebelumnya dalam pelajaran.
Dan dengan melakukan itu, kita
memberikan quantum circuit kemampuan untuk mengevaluasi operasi tersebut pada superposisi dari state klasik.
Dan seperti yang akan kita lihat, itu memungkinkan kita untuk memfaktorkan integer secara efisien.
Itulah akhir dari pelajaran ini, yang terutama berfokus pada membangun fondasi
untuk algoritma kuantum dalam kerangka komputasi standar non-black box.
Kita berbicara tentang biaya komputasi terutama melalui kacamata masalah yang terhubung dengan teori bilangan dasar.
Kita membahas biaya polinomial
versus eksponensial untuk tugas komputasi, dan kita melihat bagaimana komputasi klasik
bisa diimplementasikan oleh quantum circuit dengan cara yang bersih bebas sampah yang memungkinkan mereka untuk digunakan sebagai subrutin
di dalam komputasi kuantum yang lebih besar.
Semoga kamu mau bergabung dengan saya untuk pelajaran berikutnya di mana kita akan melihat bagaimana algoritma Shor memanfaatkan ide-ide ini, memungkinkan kita untuk memfaktorkan
integer dengan biaya polinomial.
Sampai jumpa.